there is a new bill introduced by nevada
lawmakers that would allow the creation
of so-called pot lounges so people can
consume
cannabis in public orco now joining us
live outside of
planet 13 with what this could mean for
the industry
orco well brian since 2017
locals and tourists have been coming to
nevada dispensaries
like planet 13 to buy recreational
marijuana
but to actually use it they have to go
to someone's house pot lounges would
provide
a different option planet 13 is the
world's largest marijuana dispensary but
even with all this room
customers can't consume their cannabis
here las vegas has been asking this for
a long time nevada law states cannabis
can only be used in private spaces but
planet 13
is ready to have a pot lounge a
consumption facility
that's safe for our customers and really
adds on to the experience where
you can watch products being made you
can buy products
at our facility and then you can also
safely consume
customers like the concept just hang out
with your friends
also just enjoy the products without
having to travel and wait
to do it you can just go ahead and crack
it open now a new bill could make that a
reality
the time is just right and the momentum
is right assemblyman steve yeager
recently introduced ab 341 which would
establish
pot lounges as part of dispensaries or
freestanding businesses
and although lawmakers have tried this
before they're more confident this time
around
we have the cannabis compliance board
now which is the regulatory agency for
the cannabis industry
i think they're going to have a large
role to play in helping us
make this happen clark county
commissioner tick sagar bloom supports
the bill but sees room for
improvement i'd like to see us local
jurisdictions have more
freedom as far as the kinds of lounges
we license
planet 13 hopes to see pot lounges get
the green light
we think it's something that's necessary
in las vegas
there are also concerns about people at
lounges becoming too high
and then getting behind the wheel
assemblyman yeager says the goal is to
be responsible
and just like at bars he says pot lounge
employees
can also possibly be trained on how to
identify people
who are consuming too much yeager also
points to
the large number of ride share services
that we have available
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now